[Musik]
das ganze soll
[Gelächter]
[Musik]
die company als ganzes
wiener gemeindebezirks aufrichtiges
dann waren im endeffekt zu reden so das
ist die mobilität ich angesprochen habe
das wird vielleicht auch im jüngsten
solar und sage ich dir redet ohne
training zwingend als auch den körper zu
relativ schnell weg sind
an der vierten kompanie alles gute für
den einsatz ab morgen wieder österreich
menschen die gesund mein auftrag ist
wieder gesunken
dazu absolvieren werden
leistungsbereitschaft ist unabdingbar
für die erfüllung
danke dafür wünsche ihnen für die
weitere zeit gerade und in den
diversesten funktionen die sie dann auch
übernehmen werden alle spiele
[Musik]
insbesondere werden erwarten
angelockt werden
[Musik]
da fragen wir uns wo ist der getrieben
diesen harten alltag auch in unseren
dienst alltag so viel dass wir uns bald
und erfreuen werden können
ich wünsche vor allem innen die
kameraden dass sie sich an kleinen
dingen freuen können wenn es darum geht
[Musik]
noch im einsatz heißt und ausmacht die
freude ist aber wichtig und die freude
speisen wie heute ein anderer der
kameradschaft auch was in der ganz
wesentlichen quelle nämlich aus dem
glauben jeder von uns hat einen glauben
die beziehung zu einer person zu einem
etwas zu einer überzeugung ja ich denke
wenn wir von gott sprechen wir seinen
segen erkrankung für euch insbesondere
für diesen wichtigen dienst den hier am
start und der republik österreich
leisten werde damit euch die freude des
ganzen auch nicht mehr parken kommen im
privaten wie im öffentlichen freude zu
haben ja das ist wichtig denn die freude
schenkt uns kraft hat die mutter teresa
mal gesagt die mutter von kalkutta die
freude schenkt uns kraft soldaten
brauchen viel kraft das was von ihnen
gefordert wird tagtäglich neu zu
erfüllen und zu gehen was euch dies
gelingt dazu bitte ich heute in dieser
stunde in besonderen segen für euch und
zu sehen euch gott der die liebe ist der
vater der sohn und der heilige geist
[Musik]
recht rasch angegangen
ich kann ihnen sagen für mich sind die
letzten 13 monate seit beginn der
pandemie äußerst rasch vergangen
auch aufgrund dieser vielen
herausforderungen die es in diesem jahr
mieten an vorderster stelle
und ich darf mich bei allen bedanken und
dazu beigetragen haben dass er insgesamt
seine aufgaben erfüllen konnte
[Musik]
die post verdient haben in der tat hat
oder sonst
wir waren an vorderster stelle mit dabei
und herzlichen dank dafür
für gerade musik bei der adels und der
vierten die in kürze die erste ablösen
mit und der kaffee kaufen natürlich die
dann beim objektschutz in wien zum
einfachen wird sie
die von 1000 karten leisten jetzt die
troika-experten sie versprechen unter
anderem der bevölkerung zu dienen
da konnte angesprochen das ja nicht
ausschließen kann dass das auch für sie
in den einsatz geben wird ich möchte
eigentlich es noch drauflegen ich gehe
davon aus dass es auch schon sicheren
einsatz geben wird also das würde ich
wirklich nicht überraschend aufgrund der
vielen aufgaben die sie versprechen dass
sie der bevölkerung und singen werden
sie wir hatten den schutz von triebe
leisten und da ist es wichtig dass sie
irgend welchen beitrag dazu leisten
in welcher funktion auch immer um welche
tätigkeit auch immer sie wahrzunehmen
haben wir nur wenn sie ihren beitrag
leisten dann kann das bundesheer
insgesamt die aufgaben erfüllen
und dann kollabierte möglichen schützen
für diese tätigkeit wünsche ich ihnen
alles erdenklich gute und wie wir wollen
sowohl der bundeshauptstadt und unsere
bevölkerung erschließt sich mir nicht
einfach haben sich tief in die augen
schaute dabei ab
[Musik]
sehr geehrter herr militärkommandant
sehr geehrte frau bezirksvorsteherin
hohe geistlichkeit aber vor allem sie
werden in vertretung von bürgermeister
michael noth weg darf ich ihnen die
besten grüße übermitteln und den
bankdaten dass es sich für den dienst
beim österreichischen bundesheer
entschieden haben er kann heute leider
nicht hier sein als sie können vermuten
dass derzeit jeder tag mit der cover
band und den themen wie damit verbunden
sind im rathaus damit beschäftigt ist
aber ich möchte das nicht ertragen dass
man davon ausgehen dass dort
nachdenklich machen müssen dass der
mensch eigentlich auf der welt ist und
bereit zu warten
normalerweise werden hier auch zelte
stehen es waren auch ihre verwandten der
liebsten hier
man kann auch ein getränk zu sich nehmen
und bayern machen das ist leider nicht
möglich
dafür möchte ich mich bei ihnen bedanken
für ihre hohe disziplin diesen tag
grundausbildung und es dort während
ihres dienstes an den tag legen
karuna das bedeutet sehr viel und er hat
uns wirklich eine schwierige situation
gebracht beim militär kommentaren ist
schon darauf eingegangen was das
österreichische bundesheer alles gemacht
hat und was alles geschehen ist ich
möchte dass vielleicht sogar noch
ergänzen und würde sagen das
österreichische bundesheer war in vielen
bereichen auch bremser wenn ich an die
ersten test straßen innere wo ich auch
persönlich durchgeführt werden durfte
wenn man gesehen hat mit welcher
disziplin und mit welcher eigentlich mal
auch korrektheit das ganze zeit
abgelaufen ist dafür möchte ich mich bei
ihm bedanken
aktuell sind knapp 4000 ihrer kameraden
und kameradinnen im einsatz in
unterschiedlichsten einsatz ein einsatz
der viel zu selten erwähnt wird sind die
knapp 1000 soldaten und soldatinnen die
im auslandseinsatz sind das ist neben
den belastungen die wir jetzt in
österreich haben auch eine große
herausforderung für das bundesheer und
wir stellen damit eines der größten
kommt
und beginnt in der eurozone hin würde
das alles nicht funktionieren wenn sie
nicht hier ihren dienst machen würden
als funktion soldaten wechsel taten
gardesoldaten dann würde das nicht
funktionieren dass ihre kameraden und
kameradinnen diesen dienst machen können
und sicher gehört von ihrem kommandanten
die dualität dass heute alle hier sind
und dass sie morgen ganz woanders sein
können das zeigt auch die flexibilität
des bundesheers würde ich vor allem die
freude an gesprochen habe ich glaube man
band bei gerade hat das größte lob
ausgesprochen harmlos auftreten das ist
etwas worüber sie sich wirklich freuen
können und darauf können sie stolz sein
das österreichische bundesheer kann er
stolz darauf sein wie komplex die das
aufgabengebiet des bundesheers ist ich
freue mich auch darüber dass ich
erfahren habe dass derzeit weder 229
lehrlinge aufgenommen werde natürlich
gelesen habe in wie vielen bereichen
ausgebildet wird sammlerinnen waffen
technikerinnen mechatroniker und viele
viele weitere berufe das sieht man auch
wie vielfältig des bundes ist und als
mitgliedsstaat kann ich auch aufrufen
dazu dass sie vielleicht entscheiden bei
der miliz zu bleiben dass sie sich das
anschauen
dass sie aber vielleicht auch schauen
was es beim österreichischen bundesheer
alles bio angebote gibt es ist von luft
ins land ist der alles dabei von abc
einheiten bis fernmelder bis zu vielen
internationalen sachen schauen sie sich
das an und vielleicht dass auch das
bundesheer ihre zukunft und sie finden
auch hier einen passenden job
das österreichische bundesheer ist immer
dann bearbeiten es gebraucht wird und
das hilft immer dann wenn andere nicht
mehr können
das hat man etwas gesehen in dieser
pandemie wie schnell das bundesheer mit
den ersten hercules maschine
österreicher und österreicherinnen
zurück nach österreich gebracht und das
hat man auch gesehen wie zb der masten
aufbereiten und gleich das bundesheer
die ersten waren die das gemacht haben
und dementsprechend für sich
ganz happy end wir haben heute die
bundeswehr gehört ich erwähne immer die
den letzten satz der zweiten strophe
viel geprüftes österreich ich glaube wir
merken alle in unserer familie und
bekanntenkreis dass die pandemie an uns
nagt wir merken dass wir mit
unterschiedlichsten meinungen
konfrontiert sind
was viele meinungen nur noch schwarz und
weiß wie sie sind und das ist etwas was
das österreichische bundesheer ausmachen
sie erlauben jetzt auf die republik
österreich und dass wir gemeinsam diese
republik schützen das muss unser
gemeinsames ziel sein und ich bin fest
davon überzeugt dass man nur gemeinsam
diese pandemie bekämpfen kann
in diesem sinn des lebens
[Musik]
die
dein freund sein
[Musik]
[Applaus]
gerade eintreten
[Musik]
denn
nein
nicht
[Musik]
wir sprechen hier hoffen platte meldet
die betätigung der zeitlichen angenommen
und weitere befehle
das ganze hat ihre karriere company 2
[Musik]
die company mit musik im schritt
ich bin
[Musik]